major winter storm that continues to
sweep through a large part of the
continental U.S this holiday weekend
with freezing temperatures strong winds
snow and ice at least 19 weather-related
deaths are reported dangerous whiteout
conditions Hanford road travel on Friday
from Northern Iowa to Buffalo New York
blizzard-like weather drop drivers
visibility to near zero travel
conditions aren't much better in the air
so far today more than 1300 flights have
been canceled Nationwide that's on top
of nearly 6 000 U.S flights canceled
yesterday
Naomi ruckham is at Newark Liberty
International Airport in New Jersey with
the latest Naomi good morning
for the holiday are now spending
Christmas Eve at airports across the
country and as the snow shifts to bitter
cold this weather system is proving it
hasn't moved out quite yet
from coast to coast Americans will get
that treasured White Christmas but it
comes at a cost in Buffalo New York
forecasters are predicting multiple feet
of snow through Sunday
wind gusts surpassed 70 miles per hour
with visibility near zero its complete
whiteout conditions cars will be coming
and you have to come to a complete stop
those wild winds have left hundreds of
thousands of Americans in the dark with
power outages just as record low
temperatures swoop in Denver dropped to
-24 this week and Houston hit the teens
with wind chills in the single digits
from Michigan to Kentucky and even Texas
and Georgia warming centers are now open
that cold weather there's nothing to
play with flights are taking off now but
airlines are playing catch-up with crew
shortages and de-icing slowing the
return to normal in Seattle an ice storm
shut down multiple runways I think also
just a little helpless we're just not
really sure what we definitely want to
make the most of our holiday and so
we're willing to kind of come up with
alternative options but don't know what
we have to work with those driving to
Christmas are hitting speed bumps too as
rain and snow turn to ice just in time
for Santa's arrival
the good news a big warm-up is expected
next week and at least here in New
Jersey passengers seem to be in the
holiday spirit but expect a very very
cold Christmas from every corner of the
country Dana
all right Naomi thank you